Just moments
ago, CNN's
teams on the ground
near the Israel-Gaza border.
They had to take cover, jump in a ditch
because of what was happening overhead.
And to show you these these moments,
listen to this.
Because now
I sit
down, close, close,
close.
For fun.
You're fine. You're right.
You're okay.
All right.
You're right.
Okay. That's okay.
That's the idea.
Clarissa is on the ground right now.
Of course, as it's happening.
Stand by.
Hi, John.
So forgive me.
I was slightly in an elegant position,
but we have just had a
massive barrage of rockets coming in here
not too far from us.
So we have had to take shelter here
by the roadside.
We're just about 5 minutes away.
Gaza is in that direction.
We can hear now a lot of jets in the sky.
We can also hear the
Iron Dome intercepting
a number of those rockets as they were
whizzing overhead and making impact
in that direction.
Not too far from here.
We came to this location
because this was ground zero
for this entire operation of carnage.
Hamas militants came on a pickup truck.
This is the first place
where they breached that border wall.
And they basically drove down this strip
just spraying lead wherever they went.
We saw in fact,
I was just grabbing it
before that happened
and we had to hit the deck.
But heavy weaponry is being used
so we can get up now.
Where are we moving to?
Sorry. Just one second.
Okay. Up and go. This way.
All right.
So now I can show you
the scene here.
This is where those militants first came
opening up fire on all these vehicles.
There's a baby carriage down there.
Turned over on its side.
You can see over there cleared.
And if you just show
in the distance there
some kind of strikes.
Looks like in Gaza as well.
Return fire
or is that the smoke from the rocket
launchers, forgive me,
is a little difficult
after being crouched in a ditch
to know exactly what's been going on.
But yes,
multiple casualties along this area.
You can probably see
the scale of the damage
that was done to these vehicles.
A lot of them just blew up
with the force of the ammunition
they were taking.
And they're just now
turning away the actual pickup truck
that was carrying those Hamas fighters.
And that was some resistance.
Careful, Clayton.
There were a couple of
bullet holes in the window,
shells in the windshield, rather.
So they stopped the car.
They got out of it
and they just went on this
shooting spree.
This is also,
they believe,
where a lot of hostages were taken.
They just got out of this,
started grabbing people,
started shooting people
and taking them back
to that side of the border.
We're going to get over to Nic Robertson.
But first,
John is over at the magic wall
to show
where we're talking about
where Nic Robertson is.
This is the scene of the music festival,
that music festival massacre.
It's the control
room can show John at the magic wall
so we can show them.
So, John, these in Reims, this is
this is where Nic Robertson is
right here.
This is where the music festival was.
Clarissa by the way,
we're not giving the exact location
up in this area right here, but
this is where Nic Robertson is
at the site of the music festival Kate.
Exactly.
All right.
Let's get to Nic Robertson now.
Nic, talk to us about what you see there
and also just how
more and more horrific stories
that are coming out of that massacre that
there's a lot that we can see from here
very quickly.
Garza's just over there a few miles away.
You can see the smoke rising.
We're seeing multiple impacts
over there in Gaza.
But I'm going to ask
John to spin the camera around now
on these vehicles.
Here is a situation
about to develop here.
Now, the people here are pulling
pulling the bags
from the vehicles of volunteers,
getting the identification documents
of all those young partygoers
who were who were at the party.
They were. They were.
This is where they were. Shut up.
All these vehicles were shot up.
The soldiers here
come over
to make sure that these people
have authority to do what they're doing.
Literally smashing the windows here.
I mean,
this is unfolding
around us here right now.
But these people it's okay.
It's okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're nowhere.
Okay. We're explaining. Okay.
Don't talk to me like this.
It's not use to consider.
I like this.
What is it
that they're collecting the documents.
It's okay.
Thank you.
We're collecting.
What do we know? What do we think?
This is up to him, not me.
I'm. I'm not involved in that.
So this is an unfolding situation as.
As we talked about their
passions.
As you can see,
they're really high
and with really good reason, because
this is where those young people
had parked their vehicles
for that party on Friday night.
Saturday, morning.
And this is where they rush back
to when Hamas raced in here
to start killing them.
And this is where they were shot up.
And you can see car after car after car
after car.
Here we see the bags being taken out.
But we've seen documents
lying at the side of the road.
It's confusing an active situation.
There are soldiers here.
There are
angry and upset civilians there are
volunteers taking the documents away.
But look up here
more and more of these vehicles
and it just really gives you
that sense
and understanding of the horror,
the horror of the moment
when in the early hours of the morning,
suddenly
the partygoers found themselves
being attacked by Hamas,
brutally murdering them.
We've listened to testimony of doctors
who treated some of the wounded and that
and the dying.
And they were trying to escape.
They were trying to get
they were trying to get away.
It's hard to
it's hard to overstate the horror
of what was happening here.
But you only have to
look at the way
the vehicles are part
the way that you can see
people are trying to throw themselves in
to drive away here in desperation
and just cut down
and the situation unfolds
further down the road here.
More shut up and destroyed vehicles
as more of
the partygoers were trying to leave.
But I can tell you
the situation here is very
dynamic, is very fluid. It is changing.
And as we've been driving in here
just to get to this spot,
we passed an area where Hamas fighters,
terrorists were shot
and killed by Israeli Defense Forces.
Their vehicles are lying
at the side of the road.
That bodies are still lying
And we've also seen
the biggest deployment
that we've witnessed.
So far of Israeli military defense
forces with tanks,
howitzers, armored personnel carriers
deployed out in the field
dozens and dozens of them.
That's the biggest deployment
that we've seen so far
from what we were driving down here.
We've seen a lot more
reinforcements on their way.
So this is an area
that's getting those having
increasingly more and more troops
put in here,
very close to Gaza,
as we're talking about over here.
And again,
that's the
impact of airstrikes there on on on Gaza
and their ongoing
we hear the fighter jets
in the skies above us
and then you'll see a plume of smoke rise
up from over that.
And the reason that these people
are rushing in
to take away the possessions
of all those who were
we were were killed, injured
during there during the Hamas
killing spree, that rushing in.
And they're
doing this at high speed
because they're very concerned
about the security situation here.
And what they're trying to do
is to bring information
and relief to some of those families
who have no knowledge
of what happened to their loved ones.
But you've just witnessed
what it's like here at the moment that
there are
there's multiple things going on.
And tensions are high, concerns are high.
Most of the civilian population
has been evacuated from around here.